YEAH.
THE RULES COMMITTEE FOR MONDAY
AUGUST THIRTEENTH IS HEREBY
CALLED QUARTER.
OF PC ADVISOR NOT EVEN VIEW
ACCORDING TO THESE PROCEEDINGS.
ART IS BEING MADE HAS ALSO BEEN
TELEVISED.
BOB MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL COOLEY.
CARE CUNNINGHAM [inaudible]
GALLAGHER HERE GRAYSON
[inaudible]
KAMLAGER-DOVE.
MAYES GET NAZARIAN SALAS
[inaudible]
WALDRON HERE.
WE HAVE A QUORUM AND WE HAVE A
CONSENT AGENDA TODAY.
IS OUR MOST ON THE SET UP.
SECOND BOOMER SKY HAVE SECOND BY
MISTER MAYES.
A MAN OF SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL COOLEY AYE COOLEY AYE
CUNNINGHAM.
CUNNINGHAM I. CARILLO.
AYE CARILLO AYE CERVANTES AYE
CERVANTES AYE GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER AYE GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE KAMLAGER-DOVE MAYES.
I'VE MAYES AYE KNOWS AREA SALAS.
SALAS AYE WALDRON AYE WALDRON
AYE.
THE MOTIONS PASS AND THE SCHOOLS
GLAZER GERMAN